welcome to this video yeah game 2001 is
against yacht but wouldn't wouldn't it
be funny if 2000 it would be the yard
bird game but okay it wasn't meant to be
okay so we are going to play I'm some
sort of English opening by transposition
okay yeah i think i had this against I'm
earlier queen bee three here but I
forgot forgot the Forgotten theory
really wow not just 5mm okay I can go to
sea floor right there is no we had we
are tactic winning my queen right this
would be embarrassing where it should
should be possible
hmm what is blacks play now actually
Bishop c3 and then be six something like
that i have knight c6 ideas okay i can
also take c5 however this does not make
much sense well here I can play knight
c6 and then grab on d5 which probably
does not lead to much Bishop a six is
really annoying i have no no no square
whatsoever for my queen I have night be
five though maybe that one maybe you can
take on c3 actually Bishop a six-night
b5 and takes takes Knight c3 no no no
that's not working okay whoo so this
should be possible but maybe rook c8 I
don't like my position I don't like to
have this exposed queen all the time huh
mmm interesting
play for come on I need to play I can
take it actually
I guess yes the bishop should be tools I
have Bishop a three now as an ID m-and-c
form not sure if this is totally clear I
don't know maybe a move like Quincy six
maybe Quincy six preventing c4 and
allowing the rook from evades to move
okay it looks slightly slightly off but
it seems to work
they are threatening to play something
like Bishop c4 completely blocking the
whole thing ok and now maybe I can get
counter play with the bishop coming to
the form the pressure on e2m it's a very
very bad game by black air by white
sorry not bad black it just it just
didn't really didn't really work out III
looks terribly weak but whatever the
light squares I mean why can I not take
a seven now I don't see it
check what black resigns hmm ok that was
very very unexpected I was just just
outplayed if he is playing some no move
here like f 6 or something yeah he had
already has shifted a bit with Jack
being a maid that was strange yeah wow
this was a bad position right out of the
opening I mean maybe here i'm still ok
but ah thats that's really not nice yeah
I don't know this is this whole opening
very well night 2 a-6 castles 95 ok
Quincy to a stronger now Quincy to a
stronger yeah I'm threatening to take on
d5 play three and it is just uncie for
it is really exposed i was tempted by
the more active looking position but b6
is really annoying yeah or i should have
done that which is also also possible
nothing brilliant but it's okay now yeah
i was a huge trouble and you played it
well yeah yeah I'm just toast really
yeah lucky lucky win okay thanks for
watching